and for every female film character  there are 2.24 more men just your  friendly neighborhood famine is trying  to knock down talks masculinity doing my  best  doing my best  oh my god there are more male film  characters again assuming that's true  and you got to take all this with a  grain of salt  so you're trying to prove that it's  harder to be a woman in America in the  year 2021  and one of the pieces of evidence that  you choose is that allegedly there are  more male film characters that's that  makes a woman's life harder is that when  they turn on TV to watch a movie they  see more male characters or is that  called like physical pain emotional  anguish the suicide and homelessness  drug addiction and uh unemployment  dropping out of school other you know in  prison and that's kind of tough but on  the other hand at least we have more  film characters that are the same sex as  us